Seymour Hersh author of the price of
power this morning's newspapers are full
of stories about the Kissinger
Commission on Central America meeting
for the first time yesterday what what
chances for success do you give it well
you have to hope of course as any
American would that they come up with
something wonderful I think my
experience has shown me that Henry
Kissinger is ultimately a toady and I
think he's a very safe appointment he's
going to give you what you want if
Reagan wants a very tough rattling the
sabers of Communists and geopolitical
talk in Central America he's going to
get it if Reagan wants an out if he
decides politically he needs a vehicle
to get out he could get he can get a
forward-looking report that says it's
time to disengage it all depends on what
the boss wants whatever the boss wants
Henry will Kissinger will deliver is the
general rule based on my experience he
could surprise us all he could do
something you know honest and with
integrity I don't think it's my
experience it's not very much in him
it's also my experience that his
appointment I think is a message to the
to the to the people of Central America
in Latin America here's the man who
basically in Latin America is viewed as
the guy who brought down a yen day one
again day's crime in their eyes his
basic crime was not as political Marxism
or socialism but the fact they viewed us
as being upset about the fact that he
was elected by the people a socialist
was elected he's the man who helped
Nixon bring down a unity and is his
chief deputy mr. Schlatter Minh was the
deputy chief of mission for the American
Embassy in Chile Santiago in 1970 at the
time when we know from the Senate
Intelligence Committee that there were
let's you know from an official report
that there was serious plans to have a
military overthrow so it's a terrible
message to give the people but it's very
hard to read Henry Kissinger my own
private guess is he could even do
something with Castro he may pull a
rabbit out of the Hat anything is
possible
Seymour Hersh was born in Chicago
Illinois in 1937 married has three
children
spent four years researching and writing
the price of power Kissinger in the
White House this book very big thick
book matter-of-fact expensive book
what's this retail 1995 but in the
modern-day world it could have been more
I ended up taking a smaller Commission
on each book to get the price under $20
because the it priced out at I really
care is a priced out at around twenty to
twenty three dollars which everybody
said it's too expensive for you can't
sell serious books these days so what
what crown books and some of this count
book stores sell it for twelve thirteen
dollars which is almost a rational price
among other things you currently are
writing for this magazine on a regular
basis this is the August issue of the
Atlantic the pardon Nixon Ford Haig and
the transfer of power
what it what's so far been the most
important impact that you think this
book has had on the political process if
any well certainly I didn't know when I
started I'd end up being an employment
agency for Henry Kissinger I mean that
certainly wasn't the goal and if you
think I'm happy about it you know I'm
not I'm very upset that Reagan would in
the face of a book for all the criticism
of the book it mostly is personal it so
you know the criticism has to do with
other I did a hatchet job whether I'm
obsessed with Henry Kissinger whether I
should be spending my time doing other
things and not nobody's ever gone in and
taken a chapter and open it up and said
I'm wrong or talk to the people I talked
with and get them to acknowledge that I
was miss coating him so it's there's no
question that there's some serious
issues that I've raised in the book and
then for Reagan about morality about
integrity about what the secret policy
was and for Reagan do come back and
reappoint him says an awful lot it's AI
is it anti intellectual is it sort of
sticking it or is it the fact that he'll
if Henry Kissinger consult with your
Nixon's foreign policy as well as he
obviously did maybe he can sell my and I
think it must be a lot of that he needs
a good salesman I think the most
important thing in the book as I've come
to I've been you know flogging this book
for a couple months it's been published
in June and I've been on the talking on
talk shows and doing things
it's I didn't write this but it's
finally come to me what the way I should
I should have described what they really
tried to do Nixon and Kissinger I think
it was the most serious attempt at our
constitution in our history I think
these two guys were bringing everything
into the White House as we know they
were taking all of the authority away
their real enemies were not the Chinese
of the Russians with whom they could cut
deals but their secretary defense you
know Mel Laird and the Secretary of
State Bill Rogers and the goal was to
bring all the power in there we know
Nixon when he was knocked down because
of Watergate was in the process of
setting up his apparatchik sin every
every day every cabinet if you remember
that Fred Malick was running some sort
of a program designed to get the certain
kind of personnel on every in every
cabinet and every executive regulatory
agency etc I think the goal was almost
total control and I think is is his
legacy was going to be his heir was
going to be John Connally and I think
Nixon's goal was to go out and have a 40
million dollar a year law practice now
and be able to fix anything for anybody
anywhere in the world well we won't know
the whole story of some of the money
manipulations because I couldn't find it
I could find it but I couldn't write it
I mean I was too jittery about I had a
wonderful book on foreign policy but I
learned a lot the partner story for
example is something I learned in doing
interviews I did up more than 1,000
interviews for this book and I learned
that there was no way Richard Nixon
thought he was ever going to jail he
knew you know what Jerry Ford was and
who Jerry Ford was we just don't always
I mean I hope just to ask you and I read
the Atlantic story yesterday and I
wanted why would somebody like former
President Ford talk to you when he knows
undoubtedly where you're coming from on
this thing why would he sit down and he
gave you an interview what out in Rancho
Mirage or someplace yeah well I think he
initially did not want to he was talked
into it by my friends who said you know
my god you've got to see him initially
said he's just going to I think it was
wise for him to talk to me because at
least I'm right there saying he denies
what he denies we I certainly didn't
learn anything I didn't expect to learn
but I thought it was important I think
it's important for a forum but I think
they have an obligation to talk to Pete
like me and escape you know Richard
Nixon something went Dain to see me or
doesn't deign to see very many people he
doesn't think her friendly Henry
Kissinger didn't even deign to respond
to requests with interview you know the
other contempt with which my requests
were cheated in a way though it doesn't
help you in the sense of you know it's
easier for you to say now mr. Kissinger
won't see me he won't talk to me and
there's a confrontation there that
develops well that was she had seen me
because you know he likes to talk you
know he's he's really his own worst
enemy his memoirs were my interviews
that he is these two very fat memoirs
one of the things I allege in this
Atlantic piece is that there was serious
talk about bringing out the 82nd
airborne in the weeks before Nixon
resigned Al Haig was going on talking
about the 82nd airborne he mentioned
something about one of the that was a
term that Joint Chiefs are one of the
Chiefs over thought he heard in a
discussion they were going to do it well
one of the Chiefs after a meeting with
with Nixon in the December of 73 walked
out of that meeting convinced that Nixon
was giving him the high sign to do
something you know that he was talking
about I'm your last hope the eastern
liberal establishment they you know are
going to those juice and he's they're
going to run us over and it's going to
be the end of end of the program's year
for the conservative tough programs were
going to be overrun by the left and he
thought he detected a high sign that may
have been in his own mind he asked Jim
Schlesinger was in the secretary defense
in Schlesinger didn't hear it but
Schlesinger later was among those very
alarmed when there was talk about the
82nd airborne and you know you know
where you find proof of that
it's amazing you find proof of it in
none other than kissinger's memoirs and
I wrote 3,000 page just a lot of people
bought it nobody read it I had the same
feeling about my book you know people
buy but it's hard to read if you found
anybody's read it cover-to-cover yeah
you know my wife yeah no I don't find
I'm very disappointed newspaper reviews
and I don't know why I shouldn't be I've
generally treated very favorably by the
press I really have been I have no
complaint given Kissinger status but
they really don't really know that I was
press secretary McCarthy when he ran
against Lyndon Johnson one of McCarthy's
lines that always struck me is very apt
funny but also more apt than people
realized he said the trouble of you
reporters is
he said is is your right but you don't
read and we do have that I mean there's
not enough it seems to me thoughtful
stuff that goes on in the media which
makes it possible for a guy like me to
make money and the point I'm making is
that somewhere in the middle of a second
line towards the end of Kissinger second
line when when wars I think years of
appeal he describes a meeting which Haig
says we're going to have to bring out
the 82nd airborne to protect the
president and he writes about how we
thought he was upset etcetera etcetera
Kissinger told hey whatever you know who
can believe that but I certainly can
believe the first part and it's pretty
amazing stuff somewhere in one of
Kissinger sand kissing in Nixon's
memoirs RN for those who have it at home
page 600 he has a diary entry in the
middle of the Vietnam War and it's a
it's 72 and they're trying to negotiate
a settlement in Vietnam II remember
there was a Christmas bombing there was
all this agony all this angst and he has
hay coming in Kissinger's off
negotiating in Moscow this is in April
and Nixon's mad at Kissinger is he
always was by 72 they were ended up
being terrible enemies and they still
are although they had lunch the other
day together I mean they hate each other
but you know they're they both developed
into our finest actress I mean they're
both wonderful actors Nixon and
Kissinger they defeat in any way that
much better than we have in Hollywood
there to consummate actors both deserve
all sorts of Oscars but anyway that the
point of it is on page 600 is a diary
entry Nixon has this diary that he taped
he transfer didn't transcribed regularly
but eventually got them all transcribed
for his memoirs and the entry goes on
like this there's a issue at the bait up
for debate about what they're going to
negotiate with the with the North
Vietnamese and hey comes in and Hague
says he says mr. president above all no
matter what what happens we must do
something that keeps you in office you
know there it is you're hardly we rarely
see it so clearly just sitting there
like a lump which is you know when I saw
it I want mana because that by that time
I that's what that's what that's all
that's the whole game sy Hersh authored
journalists becoming one of the more
loved and hated of the national
journalists does it bother you when
somebody really I'm worrying it calls us
more I guarantee they don't like people
don't like you is that body do you think
that's part of the game yeah well I mean
I did the I did the meal i stuff I did
the meal I Massacre stuff in in 70 or 69
when I wrote about the massacre
of all those them is those Vietnamese
civilians and children what bother me
were the calls for about three months
any time a bunch of Special Forces guys
got together at one of the bars down in
Georgia or somewhere and had a few beers
why they got to the payphone I'm
enlisted called me up and tell me what
they would tell me what they were what
they were going to do to my private
parts and so after that that didn't get
me nervous as much as it did my wife and
no I I don't like it I don't like I weep
and moan at all the I get some
wonderfully nasty review summer right
very funny in fact I just National
Review magazine bill Buckley's magazine
Vic Gould who used to work for Agnew
wrote a terribly funny review I mean
eviscerating me but it was funny you
know gee too bad you don't you know see
more see more how long how long can you
live in the 60s and 70s you know Jesus
guy Nixon he's bad but he's not Hitler
you won't be able to make a living out
of the rest of your life we you know
normally look at the morning newspapers
and and we will this morning however we
want you to get ready talk to Cyrus are
four lines from the east are already
lighted without even putting the numbers
on the screen hardly and the one from
the West which means you you're anxious
so we'll go ahead and take a call and
catch up on the newspapers as we go I
might point out that in the this
morning's newspapers that the Kissinger
panel story is buried in all of them on
the I'm just surprised personally I show
you out there's on page three in the New
York Times Kissinger panel meets for the
first time a picture of the panelists
most stories without going into detail
reflect what appears to be some
dissension among the the Conservatives
are upset about Carlos Diaz Alejandro
because they saves Cuban born he's close
to Castro Mike Barnes congressman from
the suburbs of Washington is critical
and saying he's not going to be you know
Buffalo and this Bob Strauss saying who
is a Democrat most these are Democrats
it's just saying to blow up and
Kissinger face no he's gonna he's
awfully good at that stuff I mean this
is you know what struck me about
Kissinger when he first was announced
the point was announced he had a press
conference at the State Department and
the bit that really got everybody's eye
that made all the networks and much of
the television local television coverage
I saw was his call for a moratorium on
dissent while they he said we must have
a time of quiet he said so we
and we consider the policy these are
serious moments you know I hate to say
it but the first thing he did when he
became national security adviser to
Nixon was to tell everybody we need six
months for the war in Vietnam the first
thing he wants to do is always cut off
the First Amendment that's that's the
first day let's just cut this First
Amendment stuff out you guys in the
press let's just have a time of
reflection and when you make that appeal
to a guy like Bob Strauss you're going
to win you're going to get it you're
going to get the national security
argument by him and he's going to end up
Kissinger's great skill I think is in
his ability to the staff I noticed is
very much his staff in the post this
morning there was an article describing
one of the consultants is being Winston
Lord the chairman of the four council
formulations one of his old boys from
the old days and it seems to me that his
great skill if I've done anything I
probably made it riskier for him in
terms of his ability to manipulate
people because they might be more
sensitive to the fact that they're
manipulated and that's probably a plus
but I heard shower first calls from
Boise Idaho this morning good morning
you're on the air morning Brian is Bill
yeah bill I am a regular watcher I get
up weboth it's just after 7:00 here and
I get up and watch regularly but and I'm
Kaja calling before I enjoy your program
very much and I get a lot of my news out
of it
good you get the Idaho Statesman in the
morning oh I don't take it okay oh I
just wanted to make a comment
I heard mr. Hirsch make a statement yeah
I read part of his book excerpts but not
all of it and I I just I just want him
to know this it's guys like him that I
think should be shipped out
I agree with you completely he's either
ready loved or greatly hated and I for
one am not at all a phantom mr. Hirsch
in his ill when you say shipped out what
do you mean by that well I think Havana
would be a good stuff for the first stop
but what do you what do you object to
the most i what do you object to the
most in mr. Hirsch
we've lost him well he made his point
Havana Havana what do you say to people
like it well I think most people with
all due respect to the gentleman in
Idaho understand I'm not a communist and
in fact I'm quite a very happy
capitalist and this is a great
capitalist adventure
I heard you admit that you got a
tremendous advance on this and you've
talked about the money part of it you
make a lot of money off something like
this I you could I haven't yet I mean
but I basically the reason I'm so quick
to talk about it I want everybody to
understand that it's not the total
obsession that a lot of people seem to
think it is you know her she's obsessed
with Kissinger I was very critical of
Kissinger in his policies when I worked
at the New York Times that is I wrote
critical stories about him not even
personally critical I just wrote stories
that put him in a bad light because the
facts put him in a bad light but I I
guess I should say that I didn't want to
do the book particularly until somebody
threw an awful lot of money at me and
said this is a book to do it here's
enough money you know quarter million
dollars leave the New York Times and do
the book and that's how I happen to do
the book I don't know what Fidel Castro
would make of it but the fact is that
I'm very sorry but you know I'll tell
you my attitude sir again with all due
respects have as much right to be here
as you do buddy and it's my country as
much as yours and I have as much right
to make my own as you do I'm the lime
sorry you hung up would have loved to
have talked to you but you better
understand something that even when I
was a very sharp critic of the Vietnam
War in early days when I was in the
covering the war for the AP I really
began to hate the war I always thought
that I had that that it was as much my
country as it was the generals and it is
and I there's no reason for anybody to
back down at any point about what you
think in this country Cleveland you're
on with sy Hersh go ahead please
yes mr. Hersh the only thing I can say
about your book because I haven't read
it is that I think the reaction to it is
just hilarious seems to be that the that
the Liberals are the ones that hated so
much so you muscled attacked one of
theirs which is what conservative
have been saying for years now what I
want to talk to you about is your
speaking Pfizer platform Association you
said that personal integrity is the said
I quote known in government and then you
went on to say that LBJ was been our
greatest president if it had been for
Vietnam which to me is just an
incredible thing to say in the face of
Robert Caro's book about LBJ but perhaps
you have a sort of a double standard
here and I'd like you to maybe answer
this for me about John F Kennedy and his
integrity in the light of his bringing
what Mike Royko called Bimbo's into the
White House for his quote back therapy
end quote his ordering the overthrow the
diem brothers which I think you know he
did and I'd like to know how you think
he did it
and the wiretapping of Martin Luther
King and the involving of the Mafia
perhaps through his and Giancana mutual
paramour to assassinate Fidel Castro
okay a lot on the plate thanks for all
let me just answer the of course I I
didn't say that about John Kennedy whose
presidency is terribly overrated for a
lot of reasons I'll give you some more
reasons some of the words he brought
into our national vocabulary nation a
nation-building counterinsurgency Green
Berets fortified Hamlet strategic
Hamlet's all of these words in Vietnam
that frankly led to an awful lot of
trouble and I don't believe for a second
that he would have backed out of Vietnam
I think he was committed to that mistake
as much as anybody my point about
Johnson was this that of all the
presidents it seemed to me Johnson had
the closest and was the most my remarks
stem from a conversation I had with
Claude pepper the congressman from
Florida and so the senior citizen man
who was sitting next to me on the dais
he had it seemed to me the most sense
for poor people and for the downtrodden
Lyndon Johnson I don't know whether it
was will wait Carol's Carol's book is
marvelous by the way it makes every
other's biography a joke Carol isn't up
there yet he's only up to the 50s or the
40s with Lyndon Johnson he's not into
the Senate yet even he's got two more
volumes but I do think he had a real
touch Lyndon Johnson in terms of a basic
sort of understanding of what it felt to
be poor
and what what black people and poor
white people really under fill' tan
Hispanics I do believe that and that's
what I was talking about it there's no
way I'm going to change that on the
foreign policy stuff he was terrible
what about quick comment on the
accusation about the Kennedy mafia
connection oh well I don't think there's
any question if she's talking about I'm
not sure man but but the the one thing
we do know was that Kennedy's that in
that administration we can't quite get
it to Jack Kennedy but he had to know
about it there was an attempt made
through the Mafia to assassinate Fidel
Castro you seen Sam momochi econo whose
girl was the one one of the bimbos that
Mike Royko talked about that up in the
White House one of his girlfriends that
anyway the point is that Kennedy
certainly was if that's the contact
you're talking about there certainly was
a connection between the CIA the Mafia
your favorite president in the last 20
years
ah Mike in terms of morality san diego
good morning well yeah the Union there
um pardon me yeah the San Diego Union
with you this morning no they're not
okay go ahead any political science in
the University of California in San
Diego in this summer took a class with a
professor canal at UCSD in that class we
basically took Kissinger the White House
yours is first no more and Timur
rehearses books and did a review with
them and I have basically two questions
let me ask you before you ask the
questions did you what you think of both
books well each book by themselves they
were very interesting book did did you
reach any conclusion about psy Hersh's
book did you think it was an honest look
well that's part of what as an honest
honest work that's one of the questions
because it's a question that um he
probably familiar coming from the New
York Times Book Review digest and yeah
it's an honest book but it's
got a difficulty in that you have a
disposition towards one thesis that
comes out in the end and he uses sources
that will basically reiterate that
thesis he talked about a thousand
interviews but one of the jabs at it by
the New York Times was that those are
all people there were political losers
to Kissinger okay that's what's nice
nice review from those people as far as
an interview yeah what's the question
question is where what interviews
substantiating Kissinger stuff when you
have all these interviews that are
basically are negative towards Kissinger
as a journalist do not need also other
evidence to weigh against that to
actually make that credible and second
of all there's a big disparity events
sometimes in the book and actually what
it happens is that it makes it harder to
be able to say yeah mr. Hirsch is
correct about this or yeah he's wrong
about this there's like just a small
event with him you know reading the two
books you have um in Kissinger book just
at the very beginning he talks about his
acceptance as National Security Council
of either and it talks about how
Kissinger says he goes through a long
ordeal about getting because Nixon
basically didn't like to talk very much
not getting offered the job until later
taking a week to decide and then finally
deciding and mr. Hurst says that he
actually contacted next campaign to get
the appointment and have accepted it
right away and when you see things like
that how do you tell which is correct
okay let me give you a reference go to
the New York Times I think June 11th
it's a Monday it's that it would be the
tenth or eleventh or twelfth I think
June 11th nineteen eighty-three my book
was published most of the initial news
reports was on the fact that I wrote
that Kissinger had approached both
Humphrey and Nixon in 68 looking for a
job sort of hat in hand
academic credentials in hand saying
here's what I can do for you and I also
made a very serious allegation that he
had approached Nixon with information
inside information he had learned as a
consultant to the peace process in the
Democrat in the Lyndon Johnson
administration although he worked for
Rockefeller as a foreign policy adviser
he also it's a very bright competent guy
he'd been used by the Johnson
administration as a consultant on
Vietnam and he threw that information
over the Nixon whatever he could learn
about the peace process it was this that
led Kissinger initially my book was
first published in June that denounced
the book as a pack of slimy lies the
times then in getting to the question
you just raised who to believe
interviewed the people I interviewed in
the in the first chapter of my book I
quote Richard Allen who was in 1968 was
Nixon's foreign policy advisor later
showed up as Reagan's national security
adviser I also had information from
Cigna Brzezinski although I did not
quote him directly he later did
acknowledge that I talked to him I'd
also I also had information from some of
the Humphrey aides who described letter
a letter Kissinger had written looking
for a job in 68 Ted Van Dyck was his
name one at 1/8 in particular and I
talked to other people The Times
interviewed all these people who stood
by their story Kissinger initially told
The Times it was a pack of lies by the
end of the story he was saying well I
don't recall I don't recall those
conversations Brzezinski in particular
did affirm that Kissinger had approached
presence key who was then working for
Humphrey to offer his services or to
help to offer favors Allen acknowledged
that he had as I wrote I had offered
inside information on the peace talks I
don't think there's much doubt if you go
to the I wish more newspapers would and
I'm delighted for your question as for
the question of talking to losers you're
referring to a comment from Stanley
Hoffman who reviewed the Harvard
professor reviewed the book in the
Sunday Times and long serious review one
of the things he also said is that he
ran through some of the allegations I
made about foreign policy and he said
Vallance he agreed with most of the
assertions I made that I have to say
that but he did raise a couple of points
one of them being that I talked to the
losers well one of the problems is but
somebody like Henry Kissinger there's
always losers there's nothing but losers
when the whole name of the game is to
grab all the power
the people I talked with encoded are
people who are very prominent many of
them are well-known Mel Laird certainly
nobody can say loser or not that he's a
dishonorable man William Rogers a former
Secretary of State who was a loser
nobody's ever accused them of being a
liar because they're losers doesn't mean
they're necessarily not telling the
truth and it doesn't it also doesn't
mean that I can't verify what they say
one of the people Kenneth thrush former
ambassador to the West Germany an old
friend of Richard Nixon it seems to me
if you focus just on terms of Hersh talk
to losers you're missing something which
is that I've been in this town for 25
years I know a loser from a winner and I
understand that loses because the losers
often know a great deal and are more
willing to talk it's my function to
verify what they say price of power
Kissinger in the Nixon White House
Austin Texas go ahead please you're on
with sy Hersh all right hi
John here hello go ahead please um well
basically I just had those two comments
to make I have not read a few more
verses book but
alright about in an indica raghav I
think basically what I wanted to say is
it for all the oppression that we hear
on the media how the ledges government
there is is very or president toward
this people I think is the main point
that I would like to make is this the
far left has no equivalent of the
right-wing despot and secondly the
second point I would like to make is
that for any solution to the Salvadoran
conflict there has to be a political
power sharing sort of arrangement to
begin to control the far-right structure
of government that we have in our today
and one one last comment that I would
like to make is that the Ronald Reagan
presidency is a from what I'm able to
pick up from your discussion there seems
to be some similarity in the for control
of power did I find very very scary and
okay thanks I want to ask follow-up to
that gentleman's call the Reagan
administration is an honest and the
press operation in particular we getting
honest information this morning's paper
has a story where the president
disagrees with his army chief of staff
general Wycombe that said that we
weren't ready around the world and
military affairs
Larry speaks as close to saying the
president disagrees with that what is
that is that what I think simple thing I
think the Reagan administration is not
the Nixon administration Ronald Reagan
is not as defective as Nixon he's not as
bright also and doesn't know as much and
there is something to be said in
what was very scary about Nixon and
Kissinger was how much they knew how
bright they were how crooked they were
really that was young people aren't no
no they're very desiring yeah but
they're normally conniving they're not
they're not super winners like Nixon and
Kissinger with Nicola mahir's Nixon's
been down and out for how long you know
would you buy a used car from this guy
has been asked for 20 for 30 years now
and we still gave him 60% in 1972 what a
wonderful job he did if anybody known
the truth about Nixon and 72 in terms of
the games he played with Kissinger
wiretapping the secret bombing of
Cambodia the activities against Ellsberg
the yen they stopped the domestic spying
would've been elected but he managed to
put a lid on it to get to your question
is where this is the most ignorant
comment we've ever had I think I know
we've probably had some amazingly
ignorant governments this is just a
government that really we have a a
presidency really the president simply
is not on top of issues and the tragedy
is we are in operation in Central
America in which intelligence isn't
playing much of a role because it's all
being manipulated in which the president
has made up his mind about what he wants
to do wouldn't and that's what's going
to happen and it's very sad Oklahoma
City you're on with sy Hersh go ahead
please I could mark Brian I have been
looking looking at c-span for 26 months
now I've attempted to get in previously
but I just want to commend you and the
staff for the fine job you're doing your
coverage of of journalism is such that
it does provide an outlet that most of
the channels do not have especially the
call-in shows let me interrupt to ask
you a question because one of the things
we talk about here is journalism with sy
Hersh he's been at the forefront of it
what have you what what is your your
feeling about journalists if you watched
for twenty six months you've met more
journalists than anybody else well I'm a
member of the Sam Donaldson school that
is to say I almost consider
the the world of journalism to be the
fourth arm of government that seems
awfully far out to many people it
doesn't me they did the job I invested
in writing I've done little freelancing
but to me it's become a at this point in
my life I'm not young anymore but I've
just become interested in and seeing
that the truth is presented at least as
I perceive it better in a couple Wars I
was down in Nam when the French were
getting booted out I never thought that
would happen and it did and whereas
Ronald Reagan had a change from the
liberal to the right late life I have
had the any of the effect of the last
2025 years is had just about the
opposite effect upon me how about a
question for mr. Hearst
I for mr. Hearst the only thing I can
say is that I admire I haven't read it
the price of power are reading money's
in Atlantica
that's another thing that the current
administration is created for me it's I
start reading more and I've enjoyed his
things in the Atlantic I think he's a
superb writer I would only hope that in
his wanderings and contacts Ron
Washington he can do much the same for
the current administration that he has
done for mr.
all right sir thank you for the call on
the call from San Diego triggers a
question for you they use it in schools
when you're writing these things what do
you want I mean you work for gene
McCarthy you obviously have a political
gut reaction to the world do you want
the book to have a political reaction or
do you want it to have a historical
reaction or when you're writing a book
like this spending four years what's it
all about why are you doing it mmm you
want to sell books okay that's one thing
you want to do I mean you have to say
that first you want to write a book
that's gonna it doesn't mean you change
anything this book could work because if
done right the analogy was I was
standing on you know I'm standing on a
diving board jumping into a pool I know
I'm going to get wet and I didn't know
how bad it was when I signed the
contract but I knew if I did this book
right I would find things because
Richard Nixon is a man of endless
fascination for the United States I
didn't have any grandiose ideas I really
didn't think in I I was just too busy
scrambling I didn't I I didn't think
it's going to be a book used in campuses
a lot and I frankly I'm delighted I mean
I can tell my publisher tells me that
universities call up with orders you
know reluctantly because they don't like
to order hardback books but clearly it's
going to be used in an awful lot of
campuses and I'm getting incredible mail
I'm getting a lot of mail I mean so much
mail I get nervous about being not being
able to answer at all and it's rational
male I mean people disagree with me so
clearly it's going to have an effect on
colleges and I hadn't thought about that
I had thought you tell the story about
this guy and he's out there forever I
mean you know he's out of power to keep
him out of power and let's just try and
improve I guess in my Pollyanna way if
you asked me what I thought I'm a good
old-fashioned Liberal Democrat but you
know something one of things I learned
covering the Pentagon in the middle 60s
is forget that business of of left and
right you know I said in the speech that
was shown whether it was all shown or
not I remember saying it's not whether
you're a liberal or Democrat or
a Republican or conservative or a
left-wing or right-wing words whether
your personal integrity that matters and
my stories clearly all the stories I
read about the CIA and about military
stuff I know a lot of military people I
know a lot of people in the intelligence
community whose political views and
personal views I some of the guys in the
Pentagon who I used to deal with we
couldn't agree on a social issue if we
stood in our heads I mean some of them
were very racist some of the senior Navy
officers for example West Point southern
boys but dammit they had an incredible
amount of integrity and they couldn't
stand what was going on the line they
were doing in Vietnam and it would come
to me because at least they saw me as
somebody that didn't betray a confidence
and whatever my personal views are at
least they knew where I was I wasn't
playing any games I'm a you know I'm a
liberal Democrat I mean I couldn't vote
for Richard Nixon if I stood on my head
I don't think that's the issue I'm still
a professional journalist and we know we
as journalists have to understand that
we're entitle have some rights and we
can't walk around saying we don't have
no politics we all do and it doesn't
that doesn't seem to matter very much
what matters is what we write and you
know as I said earlier somebody wants to
criticize me by opening up a chapter and
quoting people and saying they were
misquoted or showing how I was wrong or
showing us that fellow in San Diego said
that the people I used the role terribly
biased and dishonest sources who were
losers in a bureaucracy and a
bureaucratic struggle I think if
somebody would do that I just take off
my hat and bow but that's what needs to
be done it seems to me rather than go
around and talk about what my motives
were because what difference does it
make I'm a professional
so Hearst we go to Miami good morning
good morning yeah I know no comment from
Armani Florida yet I think he is good
mr. Hearst
if he ever picked up on any kind of
unofficial Red Hawk concern amongst
congressman he had the potential for
radical being radical moves by Nixon and
his people to seize power
you know if during the winding days of
his his administration and by that I
mean you know was there any contingency
plan being developed by Congressman they
had to move off well I'm going to sell a
copy of my magazine the Atlantic to you
because if you read it in the middle of
it there's a long discussion of just
what you're saying there was
concerned not by congressman but by the
Secretary of Defense mr. Jim Schlesinger
that something was afoot in the White
House and that basically he did a study
of the 82nd airborne and what forces
would be available his concern was to be
perfectly honest was that the Marines
who were very dominant in Washington
just in terms of the physical presence
there's a barracks here in Southeast
Washington there's the Quantico training
station about 30 40 miles away his
concern was that in the Marines if Nixon
asked him to do something might stay
loyal even if he asked him to do
something extra legal on grounds that
the Commandant of the Marines general
Cushman had been a personal aide to
Richard Nixon when Nixon was vice
president and it's a pretty scary story
and there I go I'm selling a magazine I
don't I don't think I think if you're
interested you can get in touch with me
through the Atlantic all they forward
everything to me promptly by the way I
point out that gentleman we've been
anxious to have on the program will be
here Monday Philip Taubman from the New
York Times the reason is it often on
Monday morning when the weekends are
slow mr. Talman has a major foreign
policy story on the front page the New
York Times it finds its way on the front
pages of almost all the New York Times
News Service papers around the country
and we want he sent some very good stuff
on Central America it's go to
Jacksonville Florida that's for sy
Hearst good morning mr. Hirsh uh I just
wanted to ask you a question in the past
10 or 12 years events and investigations
have revealed a pattern of the hiring of
xbi agents and consultants by the
political campaigns government agencies
and corporations one that his most
obvious is McCord and associates who
were security consultants for the
committee to reelect the president
Richard Nixon and more recently the
Reagan campaign
Casey and his network of retired CIA
agents and the briefing book scandal
would you care to comment on what this
practice is doing to the American system
and would you possibly write an article
about it well actually I did in 71 I
took a break from my book and I wrote a
long series of articles for the New York
Times magazine on the Gaddafi connection
this the two CIA agents Ed Wilson and
two frank terpil who'd gone to work for
Gaddafi Muammar Gaddafi of Libya and
we're training terrorists I guess
training PLO operatives in how to use
bombs etc the information they learn and
skills they learn while in the CIA all
at hyphy I would add to your concern or
to your general question by saying also
the number of CIA agents that now work
for foreign governments is a little
frightening many former retired CIA
officials are served for example there's
a fellow in very closed who was the
station chief in Saudi Arabia who
retired after a long and successful
career in the CIA was a very highly
skilled man apparently and it became
then hired on to the Saudi government in
charge of as a consultant to internal
security or a foreign security for their
just general security for the Saudi
government well that sort of
prostitution it seems to me you know I'm
one of the things you see in foreign
many foreign countries openly advertised
for retired national security agency
officials men who monitor communications
intelligence to go to work in their
communications facilities overseas so we
have a very very serious erosion of not
only not only technology but also
manpower and it does raise questions and
the briefing gate or the stories
disappeared but I I suggest to you that
it's too bad it did because I think
there probably was more to it New York
City good morning good morning first
thing I'd like to congratulate mr. Irish
on his book there because I do have the
book and I do find it very interesting
it certainly is a lot of my suspicions
in the past so let me ask you a couple
questions have you read the book in its
entirety no I just go to two weeks ago
and I'm going through it's very slow and
very carefully and I'm not missing
anything in between do you normally read
a book this size from cover to cover no
what have you learned so far well I
learned a lot that my thing is that I
think a lot of this was set up back in
the Eisenhower Nixon era and it's
followed right on through run-up to the
present and it's still going on today
with the Reagan Carter and
administration as well as
Ford administration you say going on
what is it that's going on well I find
that for instance an article appeared in
New York news yesterday on page seven or
eight which Nixon and Kissinger
confirmed one another in a hotel in New
York a secret meeting about the policy
on South America and I find that it has
been no deviation because Kissinger had
his hand in the administration's all the
way around the clock from Eisenhower
right on up to the present and like
there's a lot of dirty tricks being
pulled and the public doesn't know about
it and the most important fact is that
Rockefeller refused the presidency a
vice presidency under Nixon but he
accepted it on the 4th and everybody
knows that rockefeller one will become
president the United States and here's
something hidden behind there another
fact that I find very interesting that
Nixon told Ford who shot Kennedy and did
you sign that that was on the television
at that time there when the news media
brought it out with the transition of
power at when Ford was being elected to
being nominated for president knighted
States and there's a lot of small little
things that add up but I find that we're
being set up for another Vietnam crisis
but it doesn't indicate what part of the
world will it be South America or South
Africa but we are being set up
okay thanks for the call let me ask you
about that meeting in New York it's I
don't think it would could have been
secret had pictures in the paper
yesterday the kiss near Nixon lunch and
a French restaurant out there why would
mr. Kissinger do something like this at
this point nine years after he wondered
he's moving he's once again trying to
I'm guessing it's my speculation that's
maybe a shade one-millimeter better than
anybody else is I really don't know
let's start off by saying I don't know
my guess is he's touching all the all
the right points the tickets to punching
the tickets to for the right you know it
was Nixon still held in a great deal of
with a great deal of respect by many
people in the Reagan camp he still talks
to the president there's still some
conferring oh that goes on and I think
it's just a to show that he's going to
be a good boy you you mentioned that you
did a lot of work on that in the terpil
situation Wilson over in the Qadhafi
regime the Chad thing is all over the
front page just under worry about oh
yeah its terrifyingly stupid to go jump
into the middle of a crazy long-standing
war without any you know what they are
BG for us yeah well for what reason
first of the French of a long time
commitment in there and what you want to
do is support the French and so we're
working around the French you know and
secondly I don't wanna get into too much
detail because of suffice to say that
we've put a lot of our we've now beefed
up our forces in the Sudan and we're
going to use that as a staging area well
the fellow in Sudan the Mary's got his
own problems he's got a north-south
problem just like they have in China
there's tremendous polarization inside
his own country are you already about
Qaddafi yeah I don't think Gaddafi's
quite the madman everybody else does I
think that's much too simple-minded I
think Qaddafi is very shrewd much more
popular than people want to believe
particularly in northern Africa
San Antonio you're always sy Hersh good
morning hello my name is Bob Regan and I
got a found some different things I want
to talk about but just a really
simplified since we talked about good
bad and different president I'd like to
ask both of you to comment on this do
you think they'll ever be another Teddy
Roosevelt do you think we'll ever have
another president that will be strong
and won't back down whether it be South
Africa or Central America or whatever
the the danger whether it be communism
or whatever that one out because we were
a country that was built on pride and
power but it seems like our country
especially since the bomb was dropped
it's like we've diminished in our
Authority we've diminished and our
integrity we've diminished in every area
and it's like
I think people are tired of hearing the
rhetoric sure we got all the ship and
everything right now in Central America
I believe in Reagan but then he's on
he's scrutinized by the press and
everybody I'm sure now he don't know
what he's gonna do okay thanks
it's a broad question but the
gentleman's suggestion that Teddy
Roosevelt was a the Rough Rider the idea
that you know we're gonna go you know
I'll tell you how profoundly I disagree
with you sir it seems to me that we're
in better shape than we the fact that we
have so many doubts about our overseas
adventures to me as a plus because if
you somehow think that we can get you if
you think we came out of Vietnam with
anything in terms of a heightened
self-respect I don't think you did I
think we started something we couldn't
finish and the fact is that in this
world right now with everybody every
major power with access to nuclear
weapons you know we don't have the
ultimate terror we did it's a different
world and we have to behave differently
and we can't send our troops in the
Nicaragua like we did in the 20s and 30s
if remember it was a FDR pulled out the
Marines out of Nicaragua in 33 when he
became president I don't think we can do
it anymore I think we're going to have
to learn that there are a lot of things
in the world that we're not going to
like and we're going to have to live
with and I think a one way to to get rid
of some of that energy is maybe devote
more time and more attention to
improving conditions for all of us
inside this country which is a wonderful
country we live in the best country in
the world
I still think for all your talk about
the Minister United States those people
leaving Vietnam on boats you know where
do they want to go they're all you know
paddling you know their dream is to get
to where you know the Louisiana or
Florida I don't see anybody heading for
Moscow it seems to me we have a great
country with a great tradition and I
think we lose nothing by deciding that
we can't be the policemen of the world
and that there are other people with
other aspirations and we don't have to
put our nose in everywhere we don't have
to put our nose in Chad we can try and
restrain Qaddafi we can put every
pressure we want but we simply can't be
responsible for everything and we don't
have to see everything in terms of the
Russians are doing one thing so we have
to do the other thing that is just
lunacy price of power kiss
and the Nixon White House is the book
and the author is with us for the next
10 minutes sy Hersh let's go back to
Manhattan good morning
right how you pull good are you ok my
name is Brian also good good name yes
part of that with an eye or why all
right what I did being I've been
watching you and the rest of step
congratulations like everybody else I
think you're probably one of the most
excellent programs on TV most unbiased
and fair handed programs
I watched McNeil Lerner last night on
television a very very interesting
program they were interviewing three of
President Reagan's advisors to all South
people including the president of
Project Hope during the interview the
fact came out that he he asked if we
were getting a fair press here the head
of project tope stated that the press in
this country is very biased liberal
biased they said as far as he could see
and he's been over there in El southport
in El Salvador in South America for 25
years now as a doing charity charitable
works are very good works he says there
certainly is a communist threat there
certainly is a danger and the reasons
the people are not aware of it is
because of the biased reporting by the
liberal press who is distorted the facts
and so the American people really don't
know what's going on caller do you think
the press is bias I think that the press
is not only biased I believe that they
spiked stories that uh which shown for
instance a conservative thinking in a
good light I think that they constantly
pick up on store I I think they serve
communism I think that the liberal press
I don't say that they are communist but
I think they serve the cause of
communism this gentleman from Project
Hope and one of the other advisors said
that what the journalists seem to do
here the ones that were brainwashed into
liberal schools of journalism what they
do here is they
simply worsen to what the left in El
Salvador has to say and then they report
it they don't talk about for instance
the death squads of the left they don't
talk about what the communists castro
and russia's purpose really is over
there I think we've been fooled for
twenty years I think we lost the Vietnam
War because of gentlemen like mr. Hersh
and Bella reps look and Jane Fonda and
they got all the glory and they were put
on the front page at at times and I
think we lost the propaganda war in
Vietnam let me ask you a question man
let me ask you a question
Ronald Reagan's administration last week
I think the week before last just made a
big wheat sale to the Soviet Union the
all right a multi-million dollar we'd
sale fine what's he doing okay I'll tell
you what he's doing you see this was
another one that was blown out of
proportion by the liberal press mr.
Reagan sat down and realized in a very
practical practical way that the embargo
of wheat simply did not work that Russia
simply went to other countries and
applied the week that they needed and
the only real good that the wheat
embargo did it just heard the farmers
here and it just it was bad for this
country so we made a policy decision to
sell wheat to Russians that doesn't mean
he's feeding the Russian army or
anything nonsense that depressed he made
a practical smart decision okay hold on
hold it right there legen could save
this country from I think the West for
twenty thirty years this country has
been putting a wedge between the
American people confusing the American
people and as far as I'm concerned I
think they champion communism okay but
but but but the contradiction is just so
clear I mean um well no I'm just asking
you if they're really our enemies why do
you sell wheat to them well because it's
practical for us to do so because it's
an our best interest to sell wheat to
them because there's a weak sitting
there going bad and as farmers been
having a very difficult time making ends
meet and it was just a smart move for us
to sell wheat to them does if we did not
sell wheat to them we would not bring
Russia to its knees because we didn't
sell wheat they go to France they go to
other
as they have been doing and they get the
week anyway why do you think so many of
the countries deal with Russia if
they're if there's a Russian if there's
a communist threat don't they understand
the communist threat I don't think that
most of the world understands the
communist threat and the reason I don't
think they understand the communist
threat is because of the biased
reporting in journalism in most of the
other countries including England France
and so on and so forth it's also very
interesting of course that all of these
countries a lot of these countries that
went socialist us are stepping away from
their realizing that socialism is a
failed philosophy does not work as
liberalism as fails in this country and
I think that a lot of the people if they
had the facts if they at the press would
stop reporting accurately what's really
going on and El Salvador was really
going on in Nicaragua that the people
would be behind Reagan 100% okay let me
ask you something else sue me Brian
Mooar let me let me interrupt a second
you know in Europe most of the European
countries are more afraid of us than
they are of the Soviet Union of course
they are the presses the press is the
point for that okay okay thanks let me
approach in a different way because this
is not an unusual calling you've heard
it before from the conservative side if
you were a conservative what would you
think of the press I think the press are
terribly predictable and I think I think
Reagan's getting a reasonably good press
I think the White House can complain
bitterly about Latin America but by and
large Reagan's got a very good press
reporters like me as good report I think
the notion that the press is in you know
the press basically eats anything it's
his own I mean as George McGovern he was
chewed up worse by the press than
anybody for all the biases in the press
and there's there very easily captive
made captive that's what my book
basically is about in another level -
it's about the manipulation of the press
and I just think the problem you have is
that it's awfully hard to explain to
somebody or try to argue it somebody who
says every problem is the problem of the
liberal press nothing is going to make
the fact that it seems to me that the
Soviets have not a great investment in
Central America go away and that's
simply a fact that sits there and if the
White House had some
evidence of the contrary we would all
know it the fact is they don't
the fact is it's been a shell game for
three years and it's getting
increasingly impaired what scares me
about Central America is that Reagan's
model is the fact that the the Falklands
War and mrs. Thatcher's victory mrs.
Thatcher's victory in the Falklands and
I think that I think what you're seeing
now in the next six months is going to
be the direct politicization of the
Central American War it's going to
become an adjunct to re-election which
scares the hell out of me last call for
sy Hersh on this interesting morning
Palmdale California good morning hello I
was just one to say that mr. Hersh was
so upset about the overthrow of the
comments leader in Chile that I don't
think that he realizes the communist
threat as one in defeating Calvinism is
a threat to the world they determined
they said themselves to take over the
world and they've almost done that
they've been filled into every
government and country in the world so
far and taken over many and the news
media left-wing you're such a fish are
tearing up your part City instead of
getting behind our president like they
should
so could wipe up the Communists in a
hurry now there's a new line they're
getting out about the prison at first he
was a good guy he's only a good guy a
real good guy and a good actor but he
was really no good another get new life
things been repeated over and over and
especially by Sam Donaldson on this path
that the Reagan isn't too bright okay
like it's common okay thank you and we
have about 30 seconds well the only
point i can say is i i i think the
communists are terrified of us I mean
the Soviet Union and I think as for a nd
I think the point I'm making about the
end they was he was elected by the
people it was a democratic election in
Chile and I don't think there's much we
can do when people vote the way they
want to vote I don't think that's our
business and I think we can coexist with
the Soviet Union I don't think there's
any real problem in that I don't think
this over you know they're not coming to
California tomorrow but you know you
look I'll never convince you and you'll
never convince me but we both have a
right to say what we want and I welcome
I absolutely grant you you're right
because sy Hersh is controversial and
when did you have a chance to talk in
depth with and we stayed away from the
newspapers this morning but not tomorrow
get your newspapers out we want to go
the headlines this is the book the price
of power Kissinger in the Nixon White
House also mr. Hirsh writes for this
magazine the Atlantic and this
particular issue the pardon Nixon Ford
Haig and the transfer of power and our
shows time's up and we hope that you'll
come back sometime and continue this
discussion already but that I'm bout sy
Hersh have a nice day